here is another member of the lgbtp
community i've added the p so this is
the
lgbt you know that lesbian
gay bisexual trans community i've added
the piece so it's lesbian gay bisexual
trans potato community this is cnn's
brian stelter in the united states we're
seeing a theme of the midterm elections
emerging it's the way you can see a wave
start to form far from shore before it
breaks on the beach the theme the
talking point on the right is about
protecting kids from the dangers of
the walt disney company
really
but disney's just a stem a stand-in it's
just a symbol for something bigger a
conservative backlash to growing
acceptance of gay and transgender people
as this cnn.com reporting says three
months into the new year lawmakers in
dozens of states have introduced a slew
of bills that could limit the rights of
lgbtq americans
some of those bills are framed as
parental rights bills opponents say
they're really actually anti-gay bills
and it's easy to picture this battle
continuing right through the midterm
elections but for folks who aren't
partisan warriors this battle is
incredibly disheartening
this is bigger than disney this is a
preview of a midterm election battle
in fact it's already raging on the right
is anybody else paying attention to it
should they
so first off stealth i want to be very
clear i'll speak directly to you you're
going to be fired soon enough because no
one's watching your [ __ ] network and
you're you're an absolute joke we'll get
more to that in a second but just know
that when you're fired all you did as a
uh as a pundit or a media analyst or
whatever it is that you purport to be
all you ever did was suck up to the
power and lie and obfuscate the truth
and make everything worse and when you
are fired no one is going to subscribe
to your sub stack you'll be welcome on
locals but no one will subscribe to your
locals no you have no support all you
have is a chair which i assume is
fortified for the weight all you have is
a chair on a show on cnn on sundays a
show that existed before you and a show
that will exist after you you were
useful to the system for a certain
amount of time you potato like freak but
everything he said there was a lie or or
just a move off the truth oh it's this
is really uh people say it's about
parental rights but it's really about
anti-gay laws there are no anti-gay laws
ron desantis is not anti-gay i was at
thursday at an event where i brought him
on stage i introduced him to my husband
he congratulated us on having kids he
sent us onesies for the babies
if there was a move on gay rights do you
think i'd be screaming about it
god these people are liars and and
propagandists i don't know how that
happens to the human soul i really don't
i really i don't want to just it's so
easy you're just a grifter right like
that's the easiest thing to say are you
so confused potato are you so so
confused about what is true and what is
reality why didn't he say when he says
oh but but people really say this is
about coming for lgbt rights how about
you say what the what rights are they
coming for
are they stopping gay people from being
married are they arresting gay people in
mass are they closing gay bars are they
not letting whatever no
none of it absolutely none of it
awful awful human beings um
okay
now here is brian stelter
being destroyed so i get a little
something here today so i got a little
worked up about the potato
but there was a uh disinformation
conference going on over the last couple
days and here is a university of chicago
student asking brian stelter and a
couple other panelists a question about
the way these people lie about
everything and i i'm not kidding i think
i want to hire this kid like this is
just
spectacular take a look my name is
christopher phillips i'm a first year at
the college uh my questions for mr
seltzer uh
you've all spoken extensively about fox
news being a purveyor of
disinformation uh but cnn is right up
there with them they pushed the russian
collusion hoax they pushed the jesse
smollett hoax they smeared justice
kavanaugh as a rapist and they also
smeared nick salmon as a white
supremacist and yes they dismissed the
hunter biden laptop affair as pure
russian disinformation
with mainstream corporate journalists
becoming little more than
apologists and cheerleaders for the
regime is it time to finally declare
that the
the canon of journalistic ethics is dead
or no longer operative uh all the
mistakes of the mainstream media and cnn
in particular seem to magically all go
in one direction are we expected to
believe that this is all just some sort
of random coincidence or is there
something else behind it
it's too bad it's time for lunch
you have 30 seconds no i mean there's
there's a clock that says 30 seconds but
but i think my honest answer to you and
i'll come over and talk in more detail
after this is that i think you're
describing a different channel than the
one that i watch uh but i understand
that that is a popular right-wing
narrative about cnn i think it's
important when we talk about shared
reality and democracy all these networks
all these news outlets have to defend
democracy and when they screw up admit
it
but when benjamin hall the fox
correspondent was wounded in ukraine the
news crews at cnn and the new york times
stopped what they were doing and they
tried to help they tried to help them
get out of the country they tried to
find the dead crew members that's what
news outlets do that's how they actually
do work together to your question about
sharing those kinds of connections and
trust we don't talk about it enough
though we don't share that reality about
how that happens and with regards to the
regime i think you mean president biden
the last time i spoke with a biden aid
we yelled at each other so that's the
reality of the news business that people
don't see that people don't hear they
imagine that it's a situation that
simply is not but i think your question
it speaks to the failure of journalism
to show our work and show the reality of
how our profession operates
we have a lot of work to do i think i
don't want to make too many fat jokes
i'm
you know
he's a large portly fella that's that's
okay uh but you know his joke
immediately which is it's time for lunch
what what happens why do you joke in a
situation like that why was his
immediate move to go to a joke because
the guy told the truth that young man by
the way his name is christopher phillips
and christopher phillips if you're
watching this i just want to give you a
massive shout out you are far more of a
journalist
than anyone at cnn period why have none
of those questions been directly asked
to stelter before or to acosta or tapper
or whoever else is working at that clown
network anymore i don't know nobody gets
to ask him with questions so stelter
jokes it off first about going to lunch
and that probably was what was really
weighing on him like the guy needs to
eat every couple hours obviously um but
it's not just that it's then his answer
had nothing to do with the question he
could have addressed the sandman
allegations he could have addressed the
kavanaugh allegations he could have
addressed any of the allegations that
were laid there and how cnn lied about
those things but he turned it into
something about ukraine and that the cnn
staff helped the fox staff or something
that is nothing and he kept repeating
this phrase shared reality
shared reality well i want to be very
clear if you're watching cnn and you
believe it's true or if you're a news
anchor at cnn i do not share your
reality i don't want to share your
reality you can have your reality it's
not my reality and it's not reality
reality it's a reality and it's a
made-up reality and it's a lying reality
i have real reality uh you watching this
you have real reality and that's what we
have to protect and defend and as i keep
saying um we have to mock the hell out
of these people let them burn themselves
down and we then have to build new
things